[Musique]
et si on s'intéressait aux premiers
photomontage de l'histoire un pick up
des feux deux jeunes filles dans le nord
de l'angleterre
et le célèbre auteur comme une boys
[Musique]
alors nous sommes allés paint 1917 dans
un petit village du nord du yorkshire en
angleterre qui s'appelle cottingley et
vous avez du jeune cousine elle si
wright que 16 ans qui héberge pour l'été
sa cousine frenchies grafite qui
arrivent d'afrique du sud
les deux jeunes filles s'amusent dans la
campagne bucolique de côté mais surtout
près de la rivière b derrière la maison
familiale et pendant l'été les emprunts
que l'appareil photo du père d'élise si
keita le photographe amateur et elles
vont s'amuser avec l'appareil photo et
le père va développer les photographies
dans sa chambre noire est vraiment une
surprise
qu'est ce qu'il va voir une photo de ses
filles effet sur le coup le père se dit
ma fille elle aussi est très très bonne
du point de vue artistique et le
probablement créé des petits personnages
de carton pour s'amuser et le père n'en
fait pas un pilote du tout au même
moment la merde elle si polis qui est
une adepte du spiritisme mouvement
l'époque on croit aux fantômes on prend
aux manifestations de gens décédés va
envoyer les clichés à la société
théosophique de sa région
et c'est comme ça qu'on va s'intéresser
à ces premières images de filles
l'histoire commence à intéresser nul
autre que son art comme en dehors
l'auteur de sherlock holmes un regret
chablais ont replongé même super on est
très intéressé par cette histoire
mais il doute de la véracité des photos
au départ alors une en voie les
photographes et des spécialistes de la
compagnie kodak qui vont affirmer que
des clichés sont authentiques et qu'il
n'y a pas de manipulation du point de
vue de la pellicule photographique alors
soir tout comme un deuil s'intéresse à
cette histoire fait reprendre des
clichés ou jeunes filles en 1919 et il
va écrire un livre en 1922 sur
l'existence d'effets qui va énormément
entaché sa réputation
ce n'est qu'en 1983 qu'elle si vous
rêvez lesquels ont découpé des
feuillants carton dans des livres pour
enfants et qu'elles n'ont jamais voulu
admettre la supercherie
parce qu'elle ne voulait pas entacher
davantage de réputation alors que conan
doyle
après la la
[Musique]